In 1997, former Saturday Night Live star Mike
Myers hit comedy gold with Austin Powers:
International Man of Mystery, which was followed
by hit sequels in 1999 and 2002.
But despite the massive popularity and box
office success of the franchise, and the fact
that everyone involved wants to make another
movie, we're still waiting for the next installment…
and we may have to keep waiting.
Here's a look at why we never got to see Austin
Powers 4.
Development hell
The Austin Powers franchise generated a ton
of revenue for New Line Cinema, money which
the studio invested in films like the Lord
of the Rings trilogy.
But while that should have ensured them footing
for Austin Powers 4, New Line Cinema got themselves
in a world of financial trouble with expensive
flops like The Golden Compass and through
public accounting disputes with Lord of the
Rings mastermind Peter Jackson.
All of which led to New Line Cinema pushing
hard for Austin Powers 4 in order to shore
up their sinking ship.
But before it could get made, the studio went
under and was bought out by Warner Bros.
No wonder development on Austin Powers 4 has
stalled indefinitely.
Austin Powers 3 wasn't...good
The first two Austin Powers movies saw the
character move from cult phenom to blockbuster
franchise star, spoofing James Bond while
adding a slew of new catchphrases to our vocabulary.
"One MILLION dollars!"
But despite being a financial success, the
third film, Austin Powers in Goldmember, didn't
quite live up to the reputation of its predecessors.
It opened to middling reviews, thanks in part
to an overreliance on pop culture jokes of
the era, which have not aged well at all.
A Britney Spears cameo?
A Silence of the Lambs parody?
A scene with the Osbournes?
With Goldmember, Austin Powers lost some of
his mojo, meaning fans haven't exactly been
demanding a fourth film.
Career downturn
Between Austin Powers and Shrek, there was
a time when Mike Myers couldn't do anything
wrong.
Unfortunately for him and his fans, that time
was more than a decade ago.
Since then, it's been a rocky road for Myers,
both professionally and personally.
In 2005, Myers and his wife Robin, who he
had described as his "muse" and who urged
him to write the first Austin Powers film
to begin with, divorced.
And the one-time star suffered a string of
box office and critical bombs, including 2008's
The Love Guru — which as of the time of
this video, is still the last major film role
Myers has taken on.
Considering it's been nearly a decade since
Myers has made any movie, the chances of Austin
Powers 4 happening at this point seem very
remote indeed.
"Right.
Okay, people, you have to tell me these things,
alright?
I've been frozen for thirty years, okay?!
Throw me a frickin' bone here!"
The Animated Hold Up
So how cool would it be to see a TV series
that mixed the best parts of both Shrek and
Austin Powers?
That might sound like a pipe dream, but it
came very close to happening after Myers cut
a deal with HBO for an animated Austin Powers
series featuring Myers as the voice of both
Austin Powers and Dr. Evil.
HBO commissioned a 13-episode season, which
was going to feature the kind of adult-themed
content you would expect to see on an HBO
cartoon.
Myers even hinted at the possibility of an
animated prequel origin film for Austin Powers
as well.
And then, well, nothing happened.
HBO quietly cancelled the series, and though
neither the network nor Myers has ever confirmed
why, writer Eric Goldman has hinted that Myers
backed out of the project.
Well, we thought that was a good idea, even
if Myers didn't.
"Dr. Evil, I love your plan."
"Ja, eh?"
"Ja, Herr Doktor.
It's a REALLY good plan."
It still could happen...
Despite all the hold-ups and dead ends the
franchise has suffered so far, it's possible
that there will eventually be an Austin Powers
4 for one simple reason: Myers says he still
wants to make it.
In fact, he's been pretty consistent on this
point, telling the press in 2007, 2010, and
2016 that he was still working on the film.
Exactly what Austin Powers 4 will look like
when it finally arrives is unknown, though
at one point, Myers said the next film will
focus on Dr. Evil's relationship with his
son, Scott Evil.
"Well, don't look at me like I'm frickin'
Frankenstein, give your father a hug."
And director Jay Roach, who helmed the first
three films, has said he also wants to be
involved, which would make it a true Austin
Powers reunion.
"You know, Mike gave me the break of a lifetime
in letting me direct Austin 1.
So I'm always good to go…"
"You have any ideas about what 4 would be
like?"
Well, Larry, probably something a lot like...this:
"Oh, behave.
Yeah.
Yeah, baby!
Yeah!"
And also this:
"Get in my belly!"
And of course, lots and lots of this:
"Welcome to my new submarine lair.
It's long and hard and full of seamen!"
"Nothing?
No?
Not even a titter?
Tough sub."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!